how pretty do you need a wifey to be
a wife yeah why six six
seven
sixty what's up yeah but remember women
are looking for the eights nines and
tens because we look for twenty percent
of guys so women are more picky than men
are and this is just two two guys and if
you want for you need to understand the
most successful a guy is the more he's
gonna literally increase the percentage
like the average dude he he don't matter
if you're five that's good as long as
you're cooperative and submissive he's
good with that but majority of females
are not submissive they carry this
masculine energy about them okay I think
I think what what when you when you were
asking that question Pearl right
um one of the things that a lot of women
don't understand about men is generally
we prefer a woman's character right so a
woman could be you know there's a thing
that says oh the pretty girls are crazy
or the you know the baddies are crazy
right for a long-term relationship
that's not sustainable okay so when
you're looking for a wife
you want a woman who is going to have
good character and a lot of the time
when women have only been shown and told
that their looks are the be all and end
all they haven't had time to work on
their character and so what it is is
that they just think pretty gets them
through the door and and I've said a lot
of women do not understand specifically
that
when you have a vagina which you have
that's just not good enough
to sustain a relationship it's it's
really not and and if you think that
your vagina is going to sustain a
relationship and you haven't worked on
your character that man's gonna go
elsewhere of course I agree but then
again he goes back to the point that I
was trying to make we can say all of
that but at the end of the day women are
extremely insecure because the same way
we can say oh yeah a wife needs to be at
least a five to have a good character
you see a 10 walking down the street
you're going to be tempting that's just
men the hormones play funny games and
that's why a lot of men will have
beautiful amazing wives at home and
they're out there with side chicks and
that's not because the woman is not
submissive and doesn't know how to take
care of her man the same way we want to
you know crucify women now because it's
that time to put the you know the lens
on women we also need to look at the
fact that men are also not appreciate
the love the women that are out there I
listen I was in a five-year relationship
I have a strong character but I know how
to be a wife I know how to make my man
feel like he's in control wait can I ask
a question though you said that you go
into a relationship when you're 23 right
yeah see the thing is statistically
women and their are literally in their
whole phases from like 18 to 25 so even
if you're getting bagged when you're 23
and really you're trying to escape
because according to what the numbers
these times and this is why I say
there's no point in generalizing women
because I for my own personal experience
knowing myself even knowing these girls
sit next to me not every single woman is
wanting to escape their whole life
because if I wanted to be in whole life
I would do it for you okay so then why
did your relationship no you wouldn't do
it my relationship ended this is a funny
question because I love it when people
ask me this because they look at my
character and they think oh it must be
because the novel is you know uh
difficult to deal with no it's not I was
do you think you are no I'm actually
very easy going and this is the funniest
thing I'm a pretty girl now I grew up as
a tomboy so the boys have always been my
demand them I know how to deal with men
I know what men want I know how they
think I can get on with them the reason
why my relationship ended actually is
because I had a man that could not
actually be able to understand how I can
be all of these cool things and be
powerful in who I am he got jealous of
my light and he couldn't understand that
I could be powerful my femininity and
that where can you elaborate when you
mean powerful in your femininity I'm an
educated woman I'm funny I'm pretty if
you want when women say I'm educated
that's when they think I should be the
boss I'll tell you why I tell you by me
being educated is important I've got
three degrees you know what that means
it doesn't actually mean I have to
listen listen I'm sorry wait wait wait
let me please don't mean [__] they do
mean a lot they don't know what's the
degree what it means it means hard work
and perseverance
I went from the US to the UK your
school's easy here I'm sorry I said it
easy it's okay it's easy depending on
how you do it because I was the first
class student because I worked hard
because what I wanted was to prove to
myself that I can put myself into any
project see it through work hardly
maintain my life the way that it's meant
to be my degrees don't make me feel more
powerful than anybody my degree spoof to
me that if I put my mind to something
and I work hard I get the results so I
know that I'm a Survivor I'm a warrior
I'm a soldier and that is something that
actually a man should be very grateful
to have because that's the kind of woman
that will be able to support you when
you have a plan when you have a project
she'll be able to be there for you are
you now telling men what they're
supposed to
um value I'm telling men that they
should value actually a woman that can
help them if they're what was to end
tomorrow you would need one second
that's the problem
I tell you what the problem is
um like
um Linda said right women don't know
what men want and the fact that you
think you can sit there and tell men
what they should actually want without
actually asking them what they actually
want is the problem okay I'll tell you
how I know this do you know what women
want oh we know what we want we've been
we've been told we've been told what
women want from day one you want to
protect her you want to you want a
provider right right you want somebody
who can be a good father right
um you want someone to support your
dreams if you have them right
did I did did I you want somebody who
listens you want a man who like we've
heard all of this as men like we've
heard it for like listeners
let me let me let me ask you guys what
do you think men want oh cause I just I
just named five okay give me four hours
men want uh somebody that can be a
support system without judgment that
means that when you come home and you're
having your man problems you can
actually come to somebody and be that
person that lays down and shows some
sort of vulnerability without being
judged because a man is a man bullet
point them bullet point one that's one
you want you want somebody that can be
caring but listening to without judgment
you want somebody you can trust okay two
you want somebody that is nurturing
because that person is going to be your
wife is going to be the mother of your
children and your Offspring obviously
they have to succeed in life and you
ideally so you'd want somebody that can
nurture that and create a home out of a
house and then third you probably want
someone that can actually satisfied not
probably definitely that was that
satisfies your needs sexually no no
listen wait where is the submission part
though wait I was waiting the submission
the submission comes from the part that
where the woman is supportive submission
doesn't actually mean the new one has to
be below a man a woman needs to be
supportive or his role yeah you don't
understand why your man needs to be
supportive
you actually don't know what my name is
well I think if that's not what men want
it's the same way that women want
certain things
men then should be considered as well
what they think women want because the
problem is that people don't feel I
don't feel like people understand what
the what a partnership or unionship
means between a man and a woman there's
a lack of understanding of what you're
actually meant to be doing together so
when I name those four or five things
was I generally right yeah kind of but
not really when you just I don't know
when you spend on your rant do you think
you were generally right yes
for sure and this is the problem no
because okay so you don't you want to
woman that you come home and say you
know baby okay so so the problem so the
problem is you you think you do the
problem is the problem is you speak a
lot but you don't listen that's the
problem and so when men speak and this
and this has been the problem for like a
long time
when men start speaking and telling you
exactly what they want women find
excuses as to not give the men what
they're actually asking for okay so when
men start saying what they want women
start saying as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible